Peter ship is the connoisseur of
collapse he predicted the great
financial meltdown of 2008 and many
other bubbles previous Peter thank you
very much for joining us thanks for
having me we are in the middle of three
weeks of three trillion dollars wiped
off the map in China what is going on
there are you still bullish on that
country long term and what does it mean
for the u.s. end a you know I am bullish
but you know they have an old expression
easy come easy go you know the the paper
wealth that you're referring to didn't
exist you know a few months ago either
we had a spectacular rise followed by a
bust but year-to-date the Chinese market
is actually still positive that's not
true about the United States so you
can't talk about the wealth that was
destroyed unless you acknowledge what
was created you know prior to that but
you know just like most of the the
products that Americans buy are made in
China and most of the economic problems
that the Chinese have are made in
America because the reason that the
Chinese you know rushed into the stock
market right is interest rates are too
low in China the monetary policy is too
weak why is that because the Chinese
have decided to peg their currency to
the dollar and so they have imported our
monetary policy in order to keep their
currency from rising which would be a
good thing for the Chinese but instead
of doing that they keep creating yuan
and they keep interest rates
artificially low and so the Chinese who
have lots of savings they need a place
to put it because they can't get much
interest in the bank there is a positive
rate of inflation and so they're chasing
the stock market so real quick will they
react to this by changing their monetary
policies at long last and what is the
possible shorten your term effects for
America well eventually that is going to
happen this has been something I've been
forecasting for years the timing is
difficult I guess only the Chinese know
and maybe even the Chinese don't know
when they're gonna do this but I do
think that quietly they have been
increasing their ownership of gold we
don't really know how much gold they
have but I think it's significant they
haven't reported their numbers in years
I think it's because they don't want the
sellers of gold to know how much they're
buying because they obviously want to
buy it as cheaply as they can but I
think they're doing this for
reason I do believe that they do want to
untether their currency from the dollar
but they don't want it to just be backed
by nothing so rather than have it be
backed by dollars which really is town
him out too backed by nothing because
the dollars backed by nothing but to
back their currency by gold and at one
point all paper currencies were backed
by gold right and if the Chinese were to
back the RMB buy gold they would have
the only gold-backed currency on the
planet and it would probably be the most
desirable and the strongest currency and
will replace the dollar as a world
reserve currency were they to accomplish
this